For one story more before you leave,
'cause we gotta talk about this one.
"People" reports, Britney just inked a book deal.
Yes, Britney Spears will publish a book
(audience applauds)
with Simon & Schuster.
It's a tell-all, all about her life
and career.
What a life
and career that is.
And the deal was reportedly worth $15 million.
(audience whoops)
I'm already
on chapter seven in my head, of that book.
Can you guys wait to read that?
I cannot wait.
It hasn't been written,
but it is already in my Amazon cart.
Yeah. Yes.
It has been read,
and I would also like
to volunteer my services to write it, to ghost write it.
I've not written a book, but I feel like-
Danielle, how dare you think
that Britney needs a ghost writer?
Sorry.
How dare you.
Can I just say,
I hope the first sentence is,
"This is a story about a girl named Lucky."
(audience claps)
(cohosts laugh)
(audience applauds)
I don't wanna make this about me, at all,
I hate to do that, but I did get to do,
just throwing this out there,
a love scene with her fiance, Sam,
in a show called "Black Monday", small plug,
and I'm just wondering if I'm gonna make the book,
you know, maybe there'll be a chapter devoted-
Sure. How could there not?
How could
there not be?
Especially
with me ghost writing it?
That's right.
There's your in right there.
Who knows?
Well, I just love you guys so much,
and this has just been such a dream come true.
I mean, it's so great.
It's us
and Penn,
from here on out.
Yeah.
That's the crew,
and Ross of course.
And Ross of course.
I like that Casey, you
and I both dived off the desk in a very similar formation,
which shows me we are soul mates-
We're meant to be.
second to Danielle.
Just Spanks akimbo.
My Spanks were goin' every which way.
Well thank you Casey Wilson
and Danielle Schneider.
(audience applauds)
Hang out with them every week on "Bitch Sesh",
a "Real Housewives" breakdown,
wherever you get your podcasts.
It's one of the best ones out there,
and we will be right back.
(upbeat pop music)